hey guys it's a fear Carson here at
BuzzFeed and today I'm going to be
answering your questions while playing
with puppies and I'm so excited I'm so
ready for the puppies oh my gosh hi guys
how are we today
[Music]
sweet shall we answer some questions
first question is what what should we
say who is your biggest celebrity crush
I have to think about that for a second
with Ansel Elgort oh I think it's Chris
Pine yeah Chris Pine and Wonder Woman we
agree yeah say I agree okay oh you're
gonna pick one out for me does The
Descendants Kass still have a group text
what's the last thing you texted her
just uh discuss actually well we do have
a group text and they were in a shoot
this weekend together I wasn't able to
go because I was out of town but after
the shoot dove texted a photo of the car
right in front of her had a license
plate that said descendants so I think
it was a businessman and driving right
in front of her so we were just talking
about that how did you react when your
first castings perfectionist were you a
huge PLL fan
I actually was the biggest PLL fan and
when I was cast Marlene King herself
called me which was the craziest thing
and she told me congratulations -
failure - pretty little liar and I just
started crying and I felt so excited and
overwhelmed right were you excited - you
want to bite my finger but yeah I was so
exciting so overwhelmed and so honored
to be able to continue the legacy okay
which one do we want next what is your
favorite way to eat a potato fries
french fries do you think you're more
like Eevee from descendants or Ava from
PLL's a perfectionist I think there's a
little bit of me in both characters
Eevee is definitely much more of a lives
in a fantasy world and Ava is a little
bit more so grounded in reality so I
think in that sense I'm a little bit
more like Ava but they both love fashion
like I do and they're both incredible
stories about women who are survivors
and especially in Havis story her story
is truly remarkable and she's definitely
a perfectionist as am i so we kind of
are similar in that sense as well what
has been your best memory from filming
the perfectionist so far oh my gosh I
need my memory onset has been
unforgettable every time I get to kind
of step into her shoes and share the
camera with Janelle and Sacha is really
such an honor I think one of our
favorite days though is towards the end
of the season where we were all shooting
the finale and we had a moment that was
just very true to pl oh I don't want to
give too much away we were all dressed
up and there was something incredibly
dramatic happening and it was a really
exciting moment for all of us which of
your cast mates would you be stuck in a
desert island with PLL or descendants is
it just one or the whole cast this one I
would go with booboo Stewart booboo is
he lives in a yurt and he hikes quite a
lot and spends like days and days on
days hiking mountains so I feel like he
would be the candidate to survive on it
does aurelion list I would go with Rupa
what show would you most like to guest
star in reaching the virgin or what do
you think
I love the bull type also I'm obsessed
with Handmaid's Tale or marvellous mrs.
hazel she's amazing
I think Marlys is Mazal what's the rule
you auditioned for that you really
wanted but didn't get well actually
originally I didn't get Eevee and
originally I auditioned for a different
role and perfectionist so it's funny how
life works what is your favorite part is
loving the descendants movies also
what's your favorite thing to do with
your cast nights when the camera isn't
rolling my favorite part about shooting
descendants is everything working with
my cast being able to tell such an
incredibly important and meaningful
story and the musical numbers are always
really special you know it's a singer
and a dancer to be able to work with
Kenny and see his vision come to life
when these epic epic dance numbers just
like these guys are dancing is always
really special hi you guys should be in
the next descendants if there's another
one our last day of shooting we just
hung out all of us in our robes and
ordered all the food and went to the
supermarket and got junk food and just
kind of you know talked and had some
wine and just kind of bonded and it was
it was really nice can you tell us
anything about the music you've been
working
what are you releasing stuff I actually
was in the studio all last week and I'm
flying to LA tonight to be in the studio
tomorrow I'll be releasing quite a bit
of music this year and I'm really really
excited about it it's just I've spent a
lot of time on it and it just was really
honest and true to who I am and where I
am at this point in my life and I'm I
really can't wait to share it with
everyone
I'm excited what's your name
dad to Mimi I think I mean you're well
Robert I don't know why okay Robert
what's your favorite song for them to
send in smoothies what do you think yeah
I like that one too
do you like this one though he likes
space between or rotten to the core
yeah if one of your designs co-stars
could have guest star on the
perfectionist who would you want it to
be that's tough
honestly any of em would be would do
such a color job that would be really
fun what is your favorite thing to post
mates
Oh hosts mates is like my weakness I
love post mating junk food so if it's
been like a long day of post mates I'm
like sour candy and like white cheddar
Cheetos some ice cream I have the
biggest wheat ears of all time like the
biggest week - is there anything you can
tease about descendants three I can't
say much I can say that it is bigger
than the first two which is crazy
the music is incredible there's such a
huge range of music in the movie
Eevee's fashion has stepped up even more
her especially her iconic villain look
it's very warrior esque which is amazing
and just you know the the friendships
between us in the story that we have to
tell is really special and really almost
politically important it's really
exciting three more guys yeah I think
they lost interest in the question
what's your favorite and least favorite
[ __ ] from the original PLL series i
think caleb is my favorite i think my
least favorite was i'm forgetting
name of Emily's girlfriend before Alison
but Emison is endgame for me what are
your favorite teen dramas
I'm real watching Gossip Girl currently
so I would say Gossip Girl and PLL for
definitely my favorite last one guys
he's just out for the count he's like
I'm done okay what are you currently
watching on Netflix
I'm rewatching Gossip Girl can I talk
about something other than it looks like
a dozen to me I'm watching marvelous
mrs. Mays on Amazon which is amazing and
Handmaid's Tale on Hulu and the
perfectionist on Hulu as well I think
that's it you guys with everything oh
yeah oh yeah now you can fight them all
there you go oh yeah oh yeah
thank you so much fuss hey this was so
much fun right this was so much fun
tune in every Wednesday night 8 p.m. at
free for them to watch peel the
perfectionist or stream it on Hulu or
free for comment this handsome guy and
all these puppies are available for
adoption right now at North Shore Animal
League America so adopt adopt adopt
don't shop should we say bye
[Music]